ham is the most unapologetic vampire
she's happy to be a vampire she was done
with humanity so it's a very clear
simple character as opposed to being
myself you know human everything is so
complex nothing is black and white in
our lives for Pam it's very black and
white reverse the spell about your head
off can you do about it oh no idea fix
my Maker I am such a softy I cry about
30 times a day and some how to play this
relentless is so much fun I can't
even explain that you why that's so fun
but maybe there's a side to all of us I
have a very caustic harsh side as well
but we all edit Pam doesn't have to edit
Pam doesn't have to worry about being
liked she's completely unapologetic it
feels so freeing the big reveal happened
last week with Pam that the which puts a
rotting spell on me so my face is
falling off so I'm rotting my entire
face and I had a lens in one eye so I
couldn't see out of one eye and this to
this is all in prosthetics five hours in
makeup every day and it was really
challenging but really meaty for me no
pun intended but it was really fun